[Applause]
Joe's memory of G7 could have only
happened in heaven brain dead Biden
brings us our video of the day during a
campaign speech in Las Vegas he regaled
everyone with a story about sitting down
with friends W Mand just a few years ago
but midrand has been dead since
1996 to be fair that might be the same
Year Joe lost Consciousness roll it
Phyllis right after I was elected I went
to what they call a G7 meeting all the
NATO leaders I was in it was in the
south of England and I sat down and I
said America's back and meeter on from
Germany I mean from France looked at me
and
said said you
know what why how long you back
for f first of all Mand from Germany I
mean France so that's the part he
correct
Ed that's like saying I'm for child
labor I mean I'm sorry I'm for child
marriage at least he didn't say how in
2015 he beat up Charles deal for a quick
history lesson mid end was President of
France from 1981 to '95 and died in 96
so if that meeting happened in 2020
Biden would have been talking to a dried
out old corpse and Mand the
same C what you think of his correction
he does this all the time I mean he says
okay so I'm like kind of out of things
to say about the president thinking he
sees dead people and like that should
never be the case like I shouldn't have
had to have one take about that and this
is I've lost count at this at this point
and it's it's going to happen again no
it is going to happen again so if I had
something else I have to save it for the
next time he thinks he sees it because
we'll be doing a segment on this the
next time he does it that's true you
need to conserve your commentary on his
Dem
that he sees yes you know uh uh Brian
this is going to be the longest election
season and this is how he is now that
entire moment was screwed up the whole
speech was he had to speak four times
over the last seven days each speech had
major moments where he just became in
unintelligible let alone inaccurate what
I think is very important is Van Jones
actually said the best thing for Joe
Biden to an election is to keep the
lowest profile possible can you imagine
someone saying the best way for your
team to win is for you not to play yes
and that is really what they're saying
they used to say that to me all through
High School how dare they and grade
school right yeah you know uh Kennedy to
to Kil me's Point huh uh he's not he's
not doing the three minute like Super
Bowl Halftime interview the easiest
interview anybody can do yeah it's a
layup and it seems like a challenge but
um he's a wuss because he can't be
challenged and that's why Trump
challenged him to a debate he's like no
let's debate right now yeah you know he
knows that the contrast is in addition
to a series of ongoing indictments it's
really the best campaign tool that the
former president has yeah would be
contrasting himself with Joe Biden on a
stage answering the same questions the
difference in their energy level and
ability to put sentences together but
you know I look at something like this I
remember when Bob do 1996 when he was
running for president and he mistook the
Brooklyn Dodgers and that ended his
candidacy that's like people like nope
that's it too old but it's like you know
he's he can't even remember Emanuel mcon
yeah who's like young and vibrant and
the names don't even sound the same it's
like I they're just they're just m names
Greg that's it yeah they're just M's
Jamie do you think somebody's on his
staff is feeding him bad info on purpose
no mid's still alive yeah this it's it's
absolutely insane like I I I feel like
he let me say this I never thought I
would have something in common with the
president but we're both
speechless like I don't even know what
to say I heard that at late late night
at the bar like when you get him drunk
he talks just normal yeah right talks
with with perfect diction they should
start dressing him in whatever suit he
wants to wear when he dies just to save
time should pick it out yes all right up
next do people lack trust when wrinkles
are
robust hey Sean here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else